me I would say that
of even contemporary views about Creoles
are still driven by
same racism that characterized slavery
and then they conclude and I want to
take that conclusion very seriously that
that although you might use a little
Creole but that Mabel doesn't mean that
it's that of a linguistic structure
class of cruel energies the term Creole
is just a story call term that applies
to this particular group of languages
but not it doesn't refer to special
developmental or special structural
patterns you know they're just they're
just just a language that's on the
Crawleys okay so but then you know what
we have to ask is you know where do we
go from here so we know of that but then
what was the issue there and in fact we
can do one thing that this is from Muniz
work no this is this I like this map
because what it shows it's what we
discussed earlier right the fact that if
you really look at curls without biases
and you think of the development and you
go back in time and you think of the
development of Romance languages right
this is the way romance evolved so you
had Latin conquerors going from Rome
into go Iberia etcetera and that's how
the romance languages were created by
through conquest and contact of
populations and in the same way if you
look at you know what happened to French
when French went to North America the
Caribbean Africa all the way to Asia
that's also how we also created you'll
get it in Creole was in Creole Mauritius
Creole Creole and and this is where you
get the clear low phony right alongside
[ __ ] funny of course but the claim I've
made so far is that you have similar
patterns not only in terms of language
contact but also in terms of structural
development so from that perspective
again that cannot be Nash need not be
this is divide this phone also divide
that linguist often draw between
language change as in the history of
French and then Creole formation as in
the insufficient creole you see so mmm
we talked about these this myth about
beating the Creole so now what we could
ask you them and so now this is just it
gets you want you want to read more
about it so you can go to my website and
you can find lots and lots of arguments
against this this idea that you have
this this cycle and then let's go up to
now and here I'm going to be using some
of the stuff that I showed at the at the
UN last week so because what we want to
ask connecting to the issues of identity
and education that were touched on by
Carolyn and Rachel is you know why do
these meats and juror and then actually
now this I can go quickly actually
because you've seen a lot of these
before right but I just wanted to - so
now this is again this is that you find
this meat in you know very well read
popular newspapers magazines like
Newsweek the New York Times
Reuters even The New Yorker you know and
all of these share that something in
common that we saw earlier right that
now should be too familiar which is you
know Creoles or French patois broken
French you know they're like primitive
languages this is or this one is almost
poetic
and I like this one because it makes me
into a special specimen of humanity
right because we need us and it means
right that you don't know as I'd like to
say when I give this talk in public when
I when I switch from speaking English
just King Creole I go from being a
modern human to be a primitive human
because I can all of a sudden on my
tongue you know I get to pronounce these
linguistic fossils which are the
equipment of the Galapagos to go in and
this is this is spectacularly this is a
spectacular claim right I mean and this
is Newsweek you know this is the New
York Times it religion is to show you
are acceptable these claims are right
but then you know again to wrap up from
what we discussed earlier this is in
very much in sync with with Michelle
Hoff to you right now this is going back
to the early part of this of this class
which we will know looking at history so
what we see is that the same way that
careers have been
silence the fact that Creoles are normal
languages that has been silenced
he's also the same way that Asian
history has been silent for the same
reason because how many of you before
this class knew about fish in history
right you because you have a patient
boyfriend right yeah but but most of us
you know and when I ask that question
you know even in my in big classes like
no 24900 with hundred of students I get
maybe one or two people to know that the
Asian evolution was even more dramatic
in terms of its claims than both the
French and the American revolutions no
it was the only one in the in the 18th
century to proclaim liberty and equality
for all the only one the French one
defense that Flav's the American one
Jefferson Madison all these guys still
had plays now Haiti was the only
evolution where there was this claim for
liberty for all but you know this is
from to you that you know as Haiti was
entering history you know it was being
written about by people who could not
conceive of the Africans as equals to
the Europeans right so so according to
to you those 18th century scholars and
they could only read the news only with
the ready-made lenses and it meant that
African liberation the fact that an
African army could win over Napoleon
they couldn't process that now it was
incompatible with the area of the state
evolution and the same way for language
so the same scholars looking at heat
shields evolution we're also looking at
him at creole language and we can't
imagine for them it was impossible that
Creoles would be no more languages right
so you can just pass on that so the so
this is very familiar so this is the
root of all these myths so the root of
this means is basically the idea that
the Africans were lesser and whatever
this they could produce as language had
to be lesser therefore they could not be
part of the same kind of theory as
normal language change as
so but again you can see you know it's
the economy stupid meaning that you know
driving in fact this is not clear you
know so yesterday actually saw Chomsky
was in black matters and I asked that
question about some you know what what
came first the economy you know Empire
or or racism right because one could see
that racism is a result of Empire you
know if you want to create if you want
to make the Africans as this of labor in
order to produce wealth then you going
to demean you know the color the culture
the language or is it was we stood in
there before and therefore made it okay
to make them into slaves
that's it that's a hard question to
answer yes it's hard to know maybe the
two as Chomsky puts it the to kind of
reinforce each other you see but in the
case of Haiti to I mean we have all
these documents that show that that's
that clearly there was this one of the
driving force behind the black code
which was it could have you know to
regulate the slaves in the Caribbean
you know the driving force behind it was
economics right you know something like
that right so today that's no the Creole
black so superior because they're in the
company of whites you know something
like that you know so for all the tasks
is the Creole sleaze that I've referred
and here they decide when the closeness
or those who are born in the Caribbean
and they have African ancestry but they
were in the Caribbean and and and they
have more worth why because we are being
assimilated into European culture
talking about elimination so here
assimilation comes with the benefit as
we being assimilated you acquire and
actually this guy is the same guy
actually would came up with this
ornamental yet pass of blood right you
could compute
qualities of different mixes based on up
the quanta of blood white blood versus
black blood he also had quanta
in terms of the worth of Creole slaves
versus those of African slave
a quarter more to imagine and of course
you know they did that know what made
them better is because they had been
assimilated in this case he used a
political term embellished that the mr.
t meaning slavery by White's would
embellish the black species right so
this is some of the background behind
all these claims about Creole languages
but of course the other part of the
background that you know is the fact
that there was this evolution that had
to be silenced this is the book that you
read actually possibly that you read
about silencing the past and and so what
I'm driving at here is that all this
together you know created the roots of
these views that Creoles are special and
and again just for good measure I want
to stress again as we wrap up this
course that you know these these notions
of Creoles being lesser and to be
excluded actually they've been fought
against even in the 19th century so this
is the Salian office president and now
this is the that famous quote in french
because it's written by a french
observer and but the key point here is
the fact that the Saleen would get very
upset when someone was was back then
well back they were mad Haitian yet
because it was still under the colony
but it would tell anyone who spoke
French to him that you know why do you
speak French
you have your own language you know so
this is Creole actually I am Bill
Donohue do you have your language and as
he was looking at them with disdain why
look for another language why look for
someone else's language so so the point
is that the son in even as he was
technically a French citizen as he was
fighting for independence you understood
the power of the creole language okay
then
now that's implicit in the analysis to
remind you
this link between no politics and
identity you know as he was so this is
one of the first 1805 law in Haiti
creating Haiti right so this is a legal
one the people in the meeting the Allen
family the bank agreed to form
themselves into a free state sovereign
independent of any other power right so
this was the most disturbing part about
Haiti slavery is abolished this was 1805
at a time when both Europe and the
Americas both North and South America
including countries like Colombia
Venezuela Bolivia who actually benefited
from Haiti in terms of the own
independent state still had slaves
so Navy is forever abolished but the
part that remember is also important is
that excluding whites from owning any
piece of Haiti which has now been
changed but that part on the stress is
the fact that the same understood also
the power of identity that is its no.5
and he says that you know all exception
means difference of color will cease the
Haitians shall henceforth be known only
by depression of blacks
okay that's 1805 well well remember so
this was at the time when this was both
English and French because the son Ian
understood that he had to let the world
know that this is my position in fact
someone so this book here addresses this
question so why why were why was Italian
since he was so Pro Creole why was he
writing in French in English right and
the point is that when he was speaking
like here it was being in Creole but you
had people right for him because he was
possibly time yet yet people right for
him he wanted the world to understand
what was his position about this issue
right so he had to write in French and
English because he was speaking to not
in Haitians and he was speaking to the
worse it this is this is opposition so
beware but then of course you know
it's what this is a book from a book by
Paul Farmer so this part is moving from
1805 to the present and then to
understand why up to today they still
this struggle around the language and
identity in the Caribbean you know
especially Haiti is is yes that from the
very beginning
after independence they were all this
pressure you know for Haiti to rename
and the French Dominion and then the
than American Dominion as you know you
know America the US occupied Haiti for
15 years in the early part of the 20th
century but even in 1825 the French
managed to extract this indemnity from
Haiti for you know this is this was huge
back then I think this is the worth you
know billions of dollars anyone can
anyone read this from here what's to
read this banks and the halving of
customs charges for the French trade all
is indemnity for the losses of the
plantation owners these conditions have
cept it in 1825 lots of decades of
French domination of patient finance and
had a catastrophic effect on the new
nations Bela kept on me
despite its nominal independence Haiti
could not escape the shackles of foreign
domination the very fact of a debt to
France strikes the modern observer as
odd why might a country of former slaves
feel compelled to renew mer 8 the
fantasy for losses incurred in a war of
liberation yeah so basically it's at the
end say is that you know the elite had
to be this compromised the elite wanted
to be recognized by Europe and by and by
America okay so and so this struggle so
that question here points to this
physics program Haitian history that
from the very beginning the new elites
that became the the leader of the elite
of the country they in many ways
replicated what the French have done you
see so that's why we so this is now
after the earthquake this is from the
Boston Globe right and this is a
straight continuation
so so basically you see the cleavage is
still there right and this is the disc
leave it I think here what no one can
refer back to Karen and Rachel
presentation and this cleavage between
deleted masses also has this this
reflects this linguistic reflex where
French is the language of power versus
Creole being the language that's still
struggling to become a tool for for
liberation right so here I think we have
this tight connection is tight nexus
between language power and identity
you